[Music]
all right we have so much news for you
tonight we could actually use two hours
but we can only get tick one we have an
infuriating opening segment for you
Congress get this his spending your
money to cover up sexual harassment and
some major developing stories for you on
other fronts President President Trump
returned moments ago from his 12 day
trip to Asia we're gonna have a report
about what he's doing next and why are
immigration agents complaining about the
president will tell you that as well an
attorney general Jeff Sessions testified
today before Congress about possible
investigations into Hillary Clinton and
that uranium one deal what's coming well
we'll tell you but first our top story
pulling back the curtain sexual
harassment inside the halls of Congress
and how you're paying for the secret
settlements sexual misconduct scandals
have engulfed Hollywood media and now
politics with the Roy Moore revelations
but did you know that you've been
funding payoffs for congressional
harassment claims for decades according
to the congressional office of
compliance between 1997 and 2014
hundreds of women have been paid 15
point 2 million dollars in total in
awards and settlements for Capitol Hill
workplace violations the House
Administration Committee held a hearing
on the matter yesterday in fact there
are two members of Congress Republican
and Democrat right now who serve who
have been subject to review or not
haven't been subject to review but have
engaged in sexual harassment this member
asked the staffer to bring them over
some materials to their residence and
the young staffer is a young woman went
there and was greeted with a member in a
towel was a male who then invited her in
at that point he decided to expose
himself she left and then
she quit her job joining us now for
reaction here in Washington is Jenny
Beth Martin she's a co-founder of Tea
Party Patriots she has a new piece on
this growing scandal and Scott Bolden
former chairman of the Democratic Party
in Washington DC and a former sex crimes
prosecutor Jenny Beth let's start with
you this is so ridiculous it's
outrageous let's see in point two
million dollars and this was started by
senator I really respect and admire
chuck Grassley what was the thinking
behind this and we'll go into the
procedures that women have to go well it
was part of the Congressional
Accountability Act which you know lacks
background yes absolutely I think that
well at the time they were trying to
make Congress live under the law so they
had passed including title 7 I'm the
Civil Rights Act they're trying to make
sure that they lived under several other
laws and they also wanted to create
something to deal with sexual harassment
but in doing this they have instituted a
culture of corruption and they have
created much more intimidation for
people who want to step forward let me
say let me share this with you this is
the office of compliance the steps a
woman has to go through to file a
complaint sure first the victims get I
think we have a graphic 180 days to
complain okay that's not bad but you
should get a little bit more if you're
traumatized victims who want to continue
must start 30 days of mediation so they
forced you into mediation then finally
the office of compliance administration
does a hearing or you can file a federal
lawsuit and it's all confidential the
problem of course is pushing women into
mediation and it seems to be geared
toward stopping the claim if I look at
this as a former attorney this is kind
of pushing on oh you don't really want
to file this 1380 asian well this is all
about power and within that mediation
it's also a counseling piece and when I
first read this I said hmm what are they
counseling the women on either this
happened or didn't happen but again this
is all about power
remember elected officials on the hill
our products if you will and this the
other thing that you didn't show was the
lack of disclosure unless they go to the
court so
is all very confidential and it's all
about taking care of each other as
opposed to pulling the sheets off of it
if you will and say listen we got a
problem I think the Republicans and the
Democrats on the hill have a chance to
lead by fixing this
it's a slush hush fun I call it the show
don't say anything
in it's actually mandatory counseling
and if you've been traumatized do you
really want your employer mandating that
you must go to counseling before you can
go to mediation so now the Senate is is
working on mandatory sexual harassment
training in the Senate the house still
hasn't really been able to push through
changes all you know congresswoman
Speier who I usually don't agree with on
much but she's right on this they want
to get rid of that wait time for being
able to push through and actually file
an actual complaint but lawyer you you
know in the in the Reformation or the
the amendment to this this legislation
on both sides you've got to make it
uncomfortable for bad behavior you have
to be intentional about it one of the
most shocking things you led with was
that the public tax dollars are paying
for these settlements 15 million exactly
it's about a million a a little less
than a million a year and you know what
if you remove that rule and made the
congressman either get employment
defense insurance or made them pay out
of their campaign pack funds and stuff I
tell you you would force a lot less of
this bad behavior because that hits them
with a pot with their pockets if I have
a question there was a there was a point
in this in this research that I was
reading today that apparently a
congresswoman was warning about the
Congress men who sleep in their offices
like those are the ones you have to I
don't know if that's fair because I know
if something looks sleeping that they're
great people
right but apparently that's a problem
what is really going on here though like
what is is it just this the usual stuff
where you get into a position of power
maybe you were kind of a geeky guy in
high school college you didn't really
have a lot of chicks and then you get to
capital it's all these 22 year old gals
running around and this is nothing new I
mean I remember being in the White House
elevator during the Reagan
administration and Strom Thurmond made a
few of interesting comments to me and I
was 25 years old and this was like
laughing it was not a big deal but yeah
I don't you don't want to chill the
workplace either that's
another thing I am a little bit worried
about here where you can't even say to
someone oh you look great nice dress
like people are afraid I know now men
who are afraid to have any interaction
at any time with a woman alone because
10 years later even if you didn't do
anything you can be accused of some men
where do you go to defend yourself you
can't defend yourself so we have to look
at the other side here as well and not
make it so sterile and antiseptic or
workplace that no one even even enjoys
that the the job you're so afraid of
saying anything right you you always
have to be careful because the
plaintiffs bars made it that way the
reality though is that women are
standing up now in the last six months
to a year and San me - and I think
that's the difference because as you see
each of these industries go with these
disclosures whether it's Hollywood or
some other industry now you've seen the
government and not the government who
enforces and makes laws if they won't
lead on this then I got to tell you
we're in the space so the hip-hip-hip
accuracy bucket if you will Grassley
said it's you know if this law isn't
working to revise it change it I mean I
guess after the packwood thing they
thought this is actually gonna
accomplish something but why did it take
so long for this to get so much notice
it's just Harvey Weinstein and all the
other stuff scaling around I guess it's
just what people are talking about so
now I'm like okay Congress what are you
doing yeah I I think that that maybe
some of it and now we're we're getting a
little bit of light shed on it until we
can half ago I didn't even know this
fund existed but I tell you what it's
it's it's intimidating you're if you're
a woman who truly has been harassed in
by a member of Congress you you need to
be able to address that and to to have
it handled not be told you must go to
counseling you must go to mediation
we're gonna have you sign an NDA you can
never tell anyone it's all designed to
to shame the well-connected whether
whether the intent or not you wind up
shaming the victim and I understand also
you've got our went around trying to get
non-disclosures to write let's not
forget men and young those boys have
victimized to victimized abused and
oftentimes this happens in Hollywood but
not all only Hollywood happens in the
theater and I've been you know I've been
hearing about this for a long time this
is it's we're talking about Congress
because you know we're here in
Washington and they're the ones to us to
be the lawmakers but this is across the
board and it's people in positions of
power who usually are have some problem
within themselves they're either they
have no self-esteem or they're they were
their father didn't love them I don't
know what it is but they they don't know
how to treat people and maybe just maybe
we'll learn how to treat people better
that transparency will that transparency
that we're talking about and I kind of
inspires talking about it's going to
make it uncomfortable this is a place of
power careers are made or lost and so
you've got to make it a safe space for
women and men who are victimized by
sexual harassment to come forward to be
protected and and and quite frankly if
there is transparency I think you see
less bad behavior there are there are
people who make false charges and you
can't just say anyone who makes a charge
you know we're gonna throw laurels
around your neck I mean it's not
necessarily the case I mean it you do
have a presumption of innocence and
sometimes I think in this climate it's
so white-hot I'm not talking about ROI
more I'm talking just in general it's so
white-hot that if a woman who seems
fairly credible makes a charge your
career is over
you know it's over you have to have you
have to allow people if you've been
accused of it you have to be given the
opportunity to defend yourself and to
clear your name and you can't just try
everything in the court of public
opinion there has to be a proper process
is that where the confidentiality comes
into play what I mean are you gonna go
into Congress and have all these interns
running around if you think that my gosh
at any moment you know I open the door
for someone or I'm going to be accused
of being demeaning or her it's got to be
careful how you do this exact you can go
way overboard on the other side but one
way to address that issue is a former
sex crimes prosecutor we would require
corroboration I mean the cases where
it's one person's word against another
there's no scientific
evidence there's no corroboration
whether there was more than a sexual
touching or not it still has to be
corroborated and I think that standard
would be good in Congress too because
then you'd have that balance if you will
because congressmen want to get
reelected okay they don't want bad press
and they don't want have to go deflation
about that with the sex crimes in how
many cases where it's usually men of
course they're accused of sex crimes
domestic abuse is substance abuse
involved how on you know what quite a
bit I mean you're testing my memory but
I would say in the mood not the majority
but at least over really not well over
fifty percent I just don't know how much
but but there are other socio-economic
factors that come into play and the
other thing is getting women to come
forward and prosecute if the father on
the husband is the top breadwinner or is
needed at home with the kids I got to
tell you some women in that position
just don't feel like they have many
choices and they dropped charges against
the very people who have abused it well
and a lot of times abuses it is simply
about power it's not about abuse it's
not even about sex it's about power raw
power you guys great to see you thanks
for coming in to you thank you